ننتقل الان الى مصر محكمه الاسره في مصر
شهدت اغرب قضيه خلع للسيده تقدمت بطلب
الانفصال عن زوجها ولكن السبب سلفتها
الزوجه روت امام قاضي المحكمه معاناتها
عقب انجابها رضيعها الاول ليكون هو سبب
الخلافات والمشاكل بينها وبين سلفتها
طبعا هي زوجه اخ الزوج
اهتمت
بالزوجه التي شكشكت لزوجها ليرى الاخير
انما تفعله امرا عاديا للسيده لا تستطيع
الانجاب تابعت الزوجه مقدمه دعوه الخلع
بانها تغار على صغيرها من سلفتها خصوصا ان
اهتمامها برضيعها زاد واصبحت الخلافات
والمناقشات الحاده بينهما
مستمر لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات